all right should we talk about
ratatouille or what
so
i think that was derek poston's comment
on his apology post he said like come on
ratatouille or some [__] like that
i need to find it but yeah talk set it
up so uh patton oswald uh is this uh
comedian he was very popular i think in
like the maybe 90s 2000s he's still
really popular with his with his demo is
he yeah yeah and he'd be working all the
time i didn't know that he was this
popular he you know tj used to represent
him really yeah for 17 years and then he
left because [__] caa was hogging him
down
uh yeah it's just a real loyal guy yeah
yeah yeah super loyal guy you know you
take a picture with you know one of your
best friends and comedian then [__] on
him in the next post yeah with like a
set up picture the most hilarious thing
is the next picture
if you can go to so far she posts a
picture saying with dave chappelle
saying i got to perform one of my best
friends or one of my oldest friends in
comedy
watching him perform at an arena it's
like a private one-on-one conversation
which is true yes it's true dave is so
[__] incredible at making a small
crowd feels a big crowd feels small yeah
and then i guess he got a lot of
comments and then and he was deleting
all the comments on the original post
yeah yeah yeah and then do i just read
the whole thing that he put
so then he posts another post
and he has someone stage a picture
of him
working on his apology or something or
maybe he's working on his set i don't
know what it is yeah
i mean he's clearly in a green room and
he's like got his hand over his chin
he's like is this pensive enough do i
look thoughtful enough in this situation
like i'm sure they took this picture
like 10 [__] times before they decide
to post it which is the most loser [__]
ever right yeah yeah and he posts a
[__] picture and then does this long
caption and mark you can read the
caption but essentially
apologizing for taking a picture with
dave chappelle
to his fans that are upset by it yeah
and then i think balances it quite well
yeah where basically says like this is a
friend of mine i'm not just gonna like
stop being a friend of him because we
disagree on something and i'm an ally et
cetera and i thought that part was good
like was good because it and he gave
dave he's like i don't think i don't
agree with dave but i don't think he's
done learning and i feel guilty because
i've cut off friends in the past i
didn't agree with and i think i might
have made them more angry and hateful
and close-minded yes which is a valid
ass point i thought it was actually
really this part people are upset about
it i didn't think you should because i
think this is what we want to give
everybody we want to give everybody the
let's say the ability to change that's
actual open-mindedness yes 100
what is shocking is that
he felt like people cared
that much about how pat and oswald felt
about the world like i didn't know that
there are human beings out there that
are going
what does pat oswald think about this
like
the guy from mike and molly
what is the guy from mike and molly
think about this like how does he feel
about trans exclusionary radical
feminist what does mike and molly's side
character or is it michael molly or is
it whatever
fat people sitcom what does fat people
sitcom guy think about
uh radical feminism and what oh my god
if he doesn't post something soon about
the fact that he was at a sold-out show
arena show with dave chappelle yeah i
don't know if i'll be able to support
him yeah god forbid like the level of
[__] narcissism and don't get me
wrong to be in this business i get it
we're we all we all are narcissists 100
i named the [__] netflix special
schultz saves america
right there's narcissism out there right
and paid everybody there really well
everybody got paid really well what they
deserved
okay a lot of silence from the rest of
the room yeah
so but but to feel like you need to
address something that is
a scandal only on your own instagram
page like the world is not picking this
up nobody gives a flying [__] you have
to delete 10 comments and all of a
sudden you're like oh no this is this is
big news that level of narcissism like
that inability to see outside the world
that's some [__] weirdo [__] man
that's that weirdo hollywood [__] you
know what that i saw this picture and
again i i like his general idea his
thought like i'm not going to abandon my
friend even if i had this is good yeah
but i was i saw this and i was like dude
i'm so thankful i'm not a part of that
hollywood world because i don't it it's
either narcissism or
these [__] hollywood guys aren't
gonna give me a job yeah because i have
a picture with a guy who's seen as
anti-lgbt and you see all the people in
the comments like the other hollywood
people can't get a job no more like
sharon stone is in the comments like i
want to talk to him about this but i
guess he thinks i'm heckling or
something like that and it's just like
it's all these people the the weird
thing about patton is i guess patton has
a fan base
yeah own thing niche fan base so you
would think that he doesn't have to like
suckle off the tee to the industry like
sharon stone does like like sharon stone
exists off of the generosity of the
industry like if directors like her she
gets to be in movies if they don't she
doesn't right but it's not like sharon
stone is in the movie and we're like i
gotta drop everything and i gotta go see
this right like when the rock is in a
movie [__] show up plain and
simple yeah like the industry needs the
rock i'm watching it
he's in a netflix movie it's the biggest
netflix movie of all time boom same with
kev the industry needs cash yeah kevin
don't need the industry yep and i didn't
know where patton sat in that but now
you're telling me that he has his core
fanbase so he doesn't need the industry
he doesn't need their acceptance but
maybe there's something in him that like
he just needs them to go hey i like you
you're a good person i think he's doing
it to preserve his fan base yeah that's
the thing
he's cultivated the family fan base is
probably pretty left
and they're like kind of wokey kind of
cocky and so he is getting all these
comments and people dm and being like yo
you're a piece of [__] i'm never coming
to a show i'm never buying another
ticket blah blah and if his whole fan
base does that then that's where you're
really [__] because he's doing tickets
on the road like it looks like he's
doing big venues he's doing theaters and
a magical yeah big theater the stuff he
posts on instagram is to serve his fan
base so this is the first time he's
getting a bunch of negative [__] on a
post so he's going bat [__] crazy and
he's like oh i need to go extra my only
issue is the picture that's what i mean
yeah so it's yeah go go sorry it's just
sorry no i'm cutting you if it was just
the note i wouldn't mind you know people
just [__] hey here's my note
this is too much
writing the note and it's just uh the
hand over the mouth like you know he did
one take where he didn't have his hand
over his mouth and he's like no it
doesn't look like i'm like toiling
through these ideas let me try one more
like oh that's really good right there
that inauthenticity
that's what it is like why would anybody
even take that picture yeah like taking
the picture with chappelle and then
showing yourself on tour like even that
that's kind of cool yeah and then
showing yourself performing for all the
people yeah that's awesome you get to be
with the [__] greatest comic in the
world and you get to perform in an arena
great cool some people are going to be
upset that because they don't like
chappelle right but to really start to
think oh my god i'll never be able to
tour again if like these seven people
who might not even be my [__] fans
they're just chappelle haters and
they're gonna comment on anything that
chappelle is involved in yeah and hate
on anything that chebel's involved in
regardless who they're with nah bro
the funny part i found was that he's
doing handwriting but then this is the
ig post that he's gonna rewrite
i was thinking maybe it was like you
know some of this probably photographer
back there taking candids and maybe he
had one left over i'm trying to give him
the benefit of the doubt and be like
maybe he's like ah this is a picture
that kind of works whatever it's just
let's just throw it up there but then
just do the note yeah but don't you have
like a level of self-awareness as a
comedian where like this is wildly corny
like as a comedian you would make fun of
this yeah that's true that's true i was
never a big pat and oswald fan but i was
asking a few comics about it and i was
was he like good back in the day they're
like no he was like really funny
that was the perception that i got from
guys that i respect yeah he's he's got a
he's a comics comic guy they have a
special hymn sarah silverman a couple
other people called the comedians of
comedy they're like the comics comic but
he got big and he got industry loved the
[__] was ratatouille like that's
paper yeah so in his mind
even if this is probably true service
fan base but also hollywood broke him
the [__] off he's huge in the voice over
space ah
you know he's consistently working like
agents of the shield like movies he's
so he's a full thing oh yeah and
especially again voiceover so that's all
this is this is how do i keep on getting
the roles in high school preservation oh
okay okay okay okay okay i'm just
surprised you didn't see the backlash
coming when he posted the picture
he was too caught up in the moment maybe
i guess like but i know like if you are
in that and you understand like where
you sit in the industry and who your
audience is you don't know why you would
go out of your way to post a picture
with someone that is yes
yeah i don't know especially after you
[__] all over shane gillis because
that's the thing he was like [__]
all over shane was going through this
thing and as funny as like and shane
reached out to him to like hey can we
just talk about it and then apparently
his reaction was like he needs to do a
lot of work before we can even talk and
then all of a sudden yo [__] you dog
yeah yeah it's super corny when the
comics just [__] on comics [__] you
shorter than me
talking to shane like that damn that's
the thing that i understand like when
you see this like when you see
especially a comic [__] on on each other
it's like
there's only a certain amount of comedy
clubs
like we're gonna bump into each other
like it's gonna happen not and i'm not
saying that there's gonna be anything
violent about this but like you're gonna
have an awkward confrontation where
you're gonna have to at least explain
the reason why you were [__] on a
fellow comic right and here we are
[__] on a fellow comic yeah and i
have no problems and i don't think any
of you guys have any problems yeah
having this conversation with pat and
oswald i think pan and judging by what
happened when shane reached out to him
does have a problem having that
conversation yes so if you're just gonna
dump all over a comic who's going
through some [__] right because it gives
you social media clout
that's really what it does is like your
community starts to go oh this is
awesome you're not dumping on every
single person that's ever said something
offensive you're not dumping on the
random person right there's tons of
people on the internet every single day
they say offensive [__] yeah right why
not dump on them oh cause you can't get
clout yeah because you can't get past on
the back because sharon stone not gonna
comment on your [__] going oh my god how
amazing are you as a comic if you're not
willing to have an unpopular opinion
that bothers me i don't know that you're
not not a comic or whatever but it's
whack yeah like you got to be willing to
stand in an unpopular opinion and if
you're going to take the
pc choice on everything and i don't need
to talk to him and then
this is good but don't not talk to a
comic who you think offended you and
you're like hey
hey can we have a conversation you say
[__] you that's so whack to me well it's
just because you don't want to handle
the tough combo and i was talking to
shane about it and he was like dude i
had to have a lot of those combos like i
had like when i was used when i was like
younger in [__] comedy and i was just
like bitter and upset and just talking
[__] about everybody and then eventually
got some success i had to meet those
people that i talked [__] about yeah and
it was tough yeah but i would [__]
have them yeah and it's important to
have them yeah you can't go around
talking all this [__] and then the
second you meet somebody it's like all
peaches and cream yeah like let's have
fun let's be happy i remember you said
that about charlemagne and stuck with me
which is like that [__] was fire i had
well yeah you say better than me before
nah he was just like
when charlemagne meets people that he
talks [__] about yeah he doesn't like
shake their hand yeah not in a rude way
he goes i can't act like i haven't
talked [__] about you yeah so he was
just like he was like they reach out and
be like nah bro i've i forget exactly
how he worded it it wasn't disrespectful
but it was like i would be phony yeah if
i'm going to be all like sweet and
cordial with you knowing what i've said
right and because i would ask him advice
about that [__] i'd be like bro what do
you do when you like meet these people
it's a small world yeah and he's like
you have to keep it a hundred yeah
unless you didn't mean what you said and
if you didn't mean what you said you're
just sitting all over that man for no
reason yeah
yeah and especially when you say it
publicly
thank god i wasn't i mean i guess i was
probably more bitter because i wasn't in
any public eye at all but the [__] when
i was bitter and angry and the hate i
was spewing it's like oh thank god i
grew out of that before i got some level
of success yes yes yes
with patton's like apology thing with
him saying like i wonder how many people
i've pushed away or like that have dug
their heels into their position great
point by me cutting them off we should
all take that in and that's what i'm
hoping like maybe someone like shane
that he cut off or was talking [__]
about he looks back and goes oh yeah i
shouldn't have done that maybe i should
have reached out to him fair he does
kind of acknowledge him
like in the way that he's gonna hope
that dave changes his his point of view
i'm hoping that patton changes his point
of view ooh that's a good perspective
and it looks like from that second piece
people are criticizing him for kind of
like throwing dave under the bus on the
second piece i actually think he did
yeah i don't think he did like
i do believe he has those beliefs
meaning like i think he's supportive of
lgbt and he's an ally and i believe that
that's real i don't think he's
necessarily putting that on but i also
believe he really [__] admires dave
chappelle and thinks he's awesome at
something that he loves switches stand
up right and it's hard when you love
something so much yeah and you see
somebody that you think is so good at it
to not forgive their shortcomings
yeah it's almost like with your
grandparents it's like you love them so
much
and i never had grandparents but like
uh i imagine you love them so much that
you forgive that they might have some
like bigoted views or some kind of [__]
right yeah i think you just change the
like where the butt goes in your
perception of them like they're good but
they believe some [__] up things
whereas some random person on the
internet like yeah they're [__] up but
they might do something good every now
and again yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
give them that grace first yeah exactly
and he knows dave and he's known him for
a long time he's like oh dave's a good
guy and he's smart and he's like
intelligent yeah and he just happens to
be wrong on this issue what he also says
in the note i don't think he's done
thinking evolving seeking he's a guy
that does that so he gives him credit as
being a thoughtful guy i think he gives
davis flowers and he's like look i don't
agree with him but i'm not cutting them
off for that so in conclusion uh you
have the you have the right perspective
because we're not going to talk about
ratatouille for this [__] long you
have the right perspective uh you did it
an incredibly corny way yeah and
hopefully
uh he continues to grow and he doesn't
uh [__] on comics and uh especially
young ones who are going through a lot
of turmoil in their career yeah just for
social media clout i want shane to reach
back out and see how that's taken now oh
man you have that combo now buddy oh
that's a good idea should we do it on
flagrant
two yeah talking about social media
clown
[Applause]